I started a new caption contest with
this Photograph that you see here taken
in Milwaukee on Wisconsin Avenue
a checkerboard or chess board depending
on what you're using it for painted in
the middle of the street and this is for
I would assume the night market which we
have monthly here in the summer we block
off this portion of Wisconsin Avenue and
do all sorts of cool stuff with it and
here you can see that it is a
checkerboard there for people to play
out games on and we did in fact play me
and Maddie and I think maybe Kat joined
in as well this is from a few years back
and I got some good captions on this we
begin with talking about black
one that's a little bit trivial but I
had to look up black goes first it has
been so long since I've actually played
Checkers I didn't know which one went
and I thought that's got to be wrong
because in chess it's of course white
that goes first but apparently in
checkers it is black that goes first
then we get another one always bet on
black and that's a little bit more I
think about roulette than about Checkers
it really depends on who's playing and
how good they are then we get another
black one black tiles matter and of
course this is playing off of the black
lives matter idea but it's kind of funny
in a different sense because yes the
black tiles are the ones that you are
playing on and they do in fact matter
because you are moving around on them
it's not the pieces themselves black or
white that matters so much but the ways
in which they shift diagonally
now all those uh black references behind
us we get another one which I think is
playing off of Chess hey mate check this
out so we've got two chess terms in
there which of course is funny because
this is not chess but rather Checkers
and now both of them are strategy games
but you know Checkers has a let's say
lesser reputation than chess so trying
to inject some chess stuff in there
then we have another one which is also
mistaking this for chess so how the
fundraiser go for those giant chess
pieces this is almost a non-sequitur not
just because it's not about Chess but
rather Checkers but where are they
getting fundraiser from I suppose they
think that because it's in the street
that uh there's some sort of fundraiser
going on I don't really know
then we get one that's totally out of
left field oh what's that middle path oh
friends avoiding these two extremes a
Buddha Eureka moment Buddhism is known
as the middle path between excessive
asceticism and Hedonism and I guess you
could say in a black and literally black
and white scenario like this where you
have a black and white chessboard and
black and white pieces that there's
something of extremes involved in that
isn't there then we go on and we get
another one again kind of out of left
field
Ukraine versus Russia land mine chess to
settle the war once and for all I'm not
sure if this is a suggestion or if this
is uh attempted to be a commentary but
again not chess but rather Checkers I
think maybe some people may have
actually like looked at the picture and
projected in that it was chess because
they're unfamiliar with Checkers and you
know
should we make light of the war maybe
not but I think this is actually a kind
of funny and there are an awful lot of
landmines and these do in fact look like
landmines I was a combat engineer we
used to cut up uh wooden cylinders
essentially telephone poles to make
dummy mines we used to train on a lot of
them and they kind of do look like mines
from in the past
now we get to things having to do with
cities themselves the so-called walkable
cities and it's funny because this is
part of Milwaukee that is eminently
walkable and even more so since they
close off this uh very important
thoroughfare for the night market for
this so This is actually part of a
walkable city that is quite walkable in
this portion of it though it isn't in
every single neighborhood
new one new traffic control measure just
dropped now that is a funny one but uh
even funnier one if you know that this
is taken in Milwaukee where since covid
we have had a lot of problems with
reckless driving
and people stealing cars and you know
we've we've been implementing traffic
control measures including roundabouts
and putting up uh you know things to
block the the intersections and speed
bumps and stuff like that well this this
would in fact slow down traffic or make
it go completely around so not too bad
and then we finish up with one that I
thought was very funny explain this
atheists because I can't and of course
this is that Meme of you know claiming
that there's something that atheists
can't make sense of so therefore it must
be from God I suppose because they're
looking at gigantic Checkers pieces and
human beings wouldn't have done that by
themselves that it must be divine
intervention and of course it's not it's
just something that people put out in
the city so I think that one's kind of
funny myself
now if you want to get in on these
caption contests you want to stay tuned
to my YouTube channel and especially to
the community tab where I will post the
pictures and put out the challenges and
you know tell people hey get in on this
you probably want to turn on your
notifications that's that little bell
thing if you don't have it already
enabled otherwise you might miss out so
until next time that is the Roundup of
funny captions and I will see you for
the next installation of this once I've
picked out another good
thought-provoking comment uh catalyzing
picture